اجواء بروكسل البارده لم تمنع بدء العام
هنا مبكرا في النيتو اتفاق جديد بين اكبر
مؤسستين في اوروبا السياسيه والعسكريه لكن
صداه سيكون اكبر على حدود الحلف الشرقيه
مع روسيا بريسم بريطانيا
خلال ايام وتقسيمنا لكننا خرجنا اكثر قوه
واتحادا وفشل بروتين
اوروبا مختلفه والتحكم في جيرانه ولذلك
سنستمر في تقويه شراكتنا وزياده دعمنا كيف
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي يشكل اغلب دول حل
الفنيته يرى في الشراكه مكسبا يستفيد منه
الطرفان خاصه بعد الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اقتربنا
[موسيقى]
اكثر من بعضنا كما ادت الى تقدم السويد
وفي لندن بطلب عضويه الحلف بالاضافه الى
اعطاء مولدوفا واخكرانيا صفه مرشح لعضويه
الاتحاد
في تفاصيل الاتفاق التزام بدعم ما اسماء
الطرفان حقك كيف في الدفاع عن نفسها
وتقرير مصيرها كما جاء ذكر الصين كطرف
يمثل تحديا لمبادئ الشريكين في مواجهه
عالم يوراد تغييره حسب البيان تعاون
مستقبل كذلك يعطي الطرفين استقلاليه اكثر
في مواجهه مطالب اوروبيه متزايده بقرار
عسكري المنفصل لمواجهه اي تهديد
ياتي الاتفاق قبل اسبوع من اجتماع رؤساء
اركان الحلف لاتخاد قرار بشان ارسال اسلحه
متطوره لاوكرانيا فهل تنجح الابتسامات
المتبادله في حسم امر طال الحديث بشانه
رسائل عده حملها الاتفاق بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي ونيتو لموسكو وجيرانها وفي
التفاصيل حديث حول مزيد من التعاون
والتشارك والتزام بدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
حرب تقترب من عامها الاول عبد الله الشامي
الجزيره بروكسل